British ambassador to Russia sir Tony
Brenton is with us now hi sir Tony I
know you took the opportunity to listen
to what President Putin had to say your
initial thoughts for us please this
morning well it's a pretty significant
escalation I mean Russia so far has been
fighting this war with one hand tied
behind its back they refused to mobilize
because Putin was worried about the
effects on Russian public opinion and
they were losing the War and what Putin
has now announced is the mobilization
which he's been refusing to do since the
War Began and has now accepted the
advice of his military and has come back
to the nuclear threat in the context of
alleged nuclear threats from the West
now I don't know whether he believes
that or not but uh it is obviously a
very significant step up in the in the
rhetoric that's going on
um I haven't I I personally haven't
heard nuclear threats from the west but
um obviously he was making that speech
for
um local as well as International
consumption
um when we sorry I haven't either but
what he did refer to is the shelling of
zapparegie nuclear reactor and that was
certainly done by Ukraine and certainly
constituted a nuclear Danger
understood
um he also talked about referenda in
certain areas of Ukraine um perhaps you
could reflect on that for us as well if
you would please yes of course um the
background to this speech in fact is
moves very fast moves now that in four
regions of Ukraine uh in in the East
there are to be referenda in effect this
weekend which will ask the question do
you want to become part of Russia
um referenda in this in these
circumstances are obviously not very
um honest things and the outcome is
pretty clear that they will say yes we
in the west will say that these are fake
referenda and will will resist them but
if Putin wants to proceed to Annex these
provinces these referenda will give him
the pretext to do so and indeed a lot of
the statements he's just made is about
his determination to protect what he
sees as part of the russian-speaking
world from what he sees as Nazi
Ukrainian uh control
so what will these announcements what
impact will these announcements have on
the war in Ukraine well I mean it's yeah
the first thing I should say is of
course the ukrainians not knowing what
Putin was going to say yesterday was
saying you can make all the noise he
likes we're winning the war and we're
going to carry it going to carry on and
win the war and they have good reasons
for confidence in doing that
um on the other hand and I simply don't
know I'm not a military expert I'm sure
you have someone you can talk to what
difference the mobilizations the
reserves will make because the reserves
will no doubt need some training it will
take time to get to the battlefield and
so on the main point I think though is
that in in the eyes of the Russian
public what has so far been described to
them rather mildly is a special military
operation is now becoming much much
closer to being a real war and therefore
it becomes that much more difficult for
the Russian authorities to pull back to
surrender to
um make major concessions in any
negotiations which may come
I mean how should we interpret this is
it that they are losing so many military
personnel also known as losing the war
and this is why he's ratcheting up
matters
yeah lots of personal lots of equipment
but loss of political support not in any
huge way the vast majority of the
Russian people are pretty solid and
support Putin but a rather important
segment of Russian opinion makers which
is the right wing the veterans the
nationalists who put in you know if
Putin has a natural constituency that's
them
have become very critical of the defeats
particularly two weeks ago
um near near um
in the north of Ukraine and a lot of
what this statement is about is feeding
red meat to that constituency that he is
determined to go ahead and take whatever
measures are necessary to win the war
um as I'm chatting to you I'm reflecting
on um
Crimea and the annexation of Crimea I
mean I'm trying to second guess what
must be in Putin's mind when he's
rushing through these uh so-called
annexations of lehance curse on and
zaparitzia is he trying to put his
thumbprint on that so that when the war
does end he can claim them as he has
um Crimea I mean that was back in 2014
still under Russian control
well he he says he's protecting the
russian-speaking populations there and
he's talked in the past about genocide
absurd word of the Ukrainian occupation
um they are not as attached to these
provinces as they are to Crimea and if
it comes to a negotiation then
um bits of them I'm sure they will be
willing to to forgo
um there have been other hints not
obviously visible in the context of the
speech but for example president edoyan
of Turkey who was in New York with our
prime minister and a lot of other
leading politicians at the moment has
said he believes the Russians want to
talk and I suspect that part of the
background to this speech is precisely
to pressure the West to pressure Ukraine
initially to come back to the conference
table as a way of beginning to resolve
things
okay
um how powerful is he within uh his own
country
oh I mean he's not a complete
totalitarian dictator I mean there's
been it's been quite interesting
watching the evolution of the speech I
was following it yesterday and it was
announced for yesterday evening and then
postponed and postponed and postponed
and finally only took place this morning
now the background slap has to be an
intense cat fight within the top of the
Russian Administration about what
measures he would announce and what
words he would use now it looks as if
the the right wing the nationalists have
won that particular battle but it does
mean that there is debate at the top of
the Russian Administration about where
they want all this to go